[Musique]
oui mais seulement lundi puis cette
semaine j'ai envie d'embarquer dans un
débat qui est quand même assez
intéressant qu'un lieu non seulement les
grands médias mais aussi dans les médias
sociaux par rapport aux nouveaux ou un à
nouvelle gouverneur général qui vont
être choisis au canada pour représenter
la couronne en est aussi avec la
politique canadienne
beaucoup de raisons pourquoi c'est un
débat beaucoup d'enjeux aussi autant
pour la politique canadienne québécoise
tout le monde a un intérêt et j'ai
expliqué pourquoi moi je me suis
positionné personnellement en tant que
c'est pas une bonne idée d'avoir un
gouverneur ou un gouverneur général
autochtone pour ce rôle et le menton
très surpris parce qu'on peut croire que
oui je désire avoir quelqu'un autochtone
qui vont représenter les intérêts des
programmations des communautés
autochtones métis inuits au sein du
gouvernement mais la raison pourquoi je
trouve que c'est pas une si bonne idée
c'est pour oublier que j'ai d'une
mouvance appel à long moment et en 2012
on s'est mobilisé en ruine à manifester
on a demandé aussi à ce que le
gouvernement harper rencontre la cheffe
des réseaux spence à l'époque qui était
sur la colline qui est en grève de la
faim et cette demande qui avait été
faite était pour avoir une rencontre
avec le gouvernement des représentants
autochtones mais aussi le gouverneur
général et pourquoi pourquoi cette
position c'est important de gouverneur
général beaucoup de chance a demandé à
l'époque mais pourquoi ils veulent le
gouverneur général ça sert à rien c'est
pas important c'est un rôle symbolique
mais pour les communautés autochtones
qui ne reconnaissent pas la colonisation
qui ne reconnaissent pas le gouvernement
canadien comme une autorité légale sur
la vie des communautés autochtones et
qui parle de nation à nation c'est à
dire qu'ils parlent d'une position de
communauté autochtone qui sont libres
qui ont des gouvernements déjà en place
qui ne sont pas nécessairement sous la
loi sur les indiens et bien le
gouvernant générale représentait l'état
canadien
mais une façon où l'état canadien lui
est distinct de l'état autochtone et ça
c'est difficile à expliquer les deux
attaquants puisqu'on les multiples
puisqu'on a plusieurs nations puisqu'on
n'a pas une seule forme de gouvernement
à l'époque une des formes de gouvernance
qui ont représenté justement les
communautés autochtones ont été
charmants atleo qui était représentant
de l'apn à l'époque
est ce que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas
compris c'est quelqu'un plutôt que de
suivre la demande du grand groupe parce
qu'on avait réussi à réunir quand même
extrêmement grosse masse critique
autochtone qui ne se reconnaissaient pas
nécessairement dans les mêmes formes
politique que ce soit certains qui font
la politique au niveau du gouvernement
canadien certains qui font de la
politique au niveau de la loi sur les
indiens certains qui font la gouvernance
traditionnel mais pour une fois on était
tous ensemble pour marcher dans la rue
pour produire on veut se faire un port
en tant que peuple autochtone et le fait
que pour gagner une rencontre avec le
gouvernement harper pour que tereos
peines puissent rencontrer dans notre
peur eh bien ils ont fait fi quand même
de certaines des demandes
est ce que ça a fait ainsi que ça l'a un
peu dévalorisés des désassembler aussi
la militance autochtone au sein que
certaines formes de gouvernement ou de
gouvernance autochtone travailler au
sein d'un système qui avait été forcée
mais qui fait quand même en place donc
l'importance du rôle du gouverneur
général c'est à dire est ce qu'on veut
par des nous en tant que grand groupe
face à celui qui représenterait la
couronne lempire un britannique qui à
l'époque avait fait les traités avaient
fait les rencontres avaient fait les
enfants ou est-ce qu'on veut se tourner
vers le nouveau gouvernement qui a été
choisie qui lui a à travers les années
décidé que le gouverneur général d'un
rôle symbolique et donc se mélanger dans
cette politique là alors une distinction
politique qui est importante au niveau
symbole et au niveau aussi des pratiques
traditionnelles la séparation aussi des
formes de gouvernance au sein même des
communautés autochtones étaient en place
donc demandé pourquoi d'abord toutes
époques ce soit sow est ce que ça
pourrait pas justement représenté les
intérêts autochtones représentent pour
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
autochtone 30 le rôle de gouverneur
général c'est représenter la reine
d'angleterre au sein du gouvernement
canadien
on sait que ça pas autant d'importance
autant de poids qu'on pourrait le croire
mais c'est un roc et là quand même pas
pouvoir réunir ces deux
deux écoles dans un niveau politique
dans un niveau de solidarité ce soit en
temps de guerre vous comme ailier mais
pour les communautés autochtones
ça reste c'est la reine donc si on met
quelqu'un qui fait partie du groupe qui
a une problématique notamment de
gouvernance avec un collègue à table
dans un rôle qui représente sept
couronnes là est-ce que c'est pas m
j'utilise vraiment une imagerie très
simple mais ce que c'est pas de dire du
prisonnier thème les clichois donne une
bonne job bien pays
qu'est ce que tu fais ta rôle est ce que
tu vas ouvrir les portes de la prison
ils idée celle là masque ou est ce que
tu vas juste décidé de repeindre le
médecin confortable donc pour beaucoup
de gens il ya une idéologie derrière le
rôle du gouverneur général qui ne peut
pas être mélangées avec le fait d'être
autochtone avec l'identité autochtone et
ça ça veut pas dire que le gouverneur
général qui va être choisi ne peut pas
être doc tonnes ce qui serait difficile
par exemple c'est d'avoir un gouvernant
général autochtone donc que son identité
culturelle ou raciales de vienne a posé
à son titre parce que la personne qui va
être la position si elle est exacte on
va recevoir énormément doit être même
probablement traités comme de travail
tout va mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
c'est 7 sur un gros chèque
c'est s'éteindront qu'un individu peut
choisir de faire ne peux pas le faire
pour représenter la communauté parce que
ça l'aurait un poids politique un poids
historique pour les communautés
autochtones qui ne se sentent pas et qui
ne sont pas représentés chemin par la
couronne britannique ou par le
gouvernement canadien puisqu'ils sont
encore indépendants qui sont encore sous
colonisation sous sous un gouvernement
qui est fort c'est sûr
donc c'est problématique c'est sûr que
beaucoup de gens qui vont encourager ça
beaucoup de formes de gouvernance ou six
attaquants dire oui on va avoir une
personne au pouvoir qui est autochtone
mais juste vous rappeler qu on a eu une
ministre de la justice cité autochtone
et quand ce rôle lui a été retiré la
fureur était pas seulement ce que c'est
une femme qui était
bonne dans son rôle qui avait sa place
mais ceux qui ont enlevé un rôle qui
était ce poète un rôle de l'association
autochtone donc c'est la minustah
justice autochtone et pas juste une
liste d'injustice tout qui avait émis
auto c'est vraiment pour souligner son
identité et des réconciliations donc
faut faire attention dans ce rôle parce
qu'il se mélangent avec une identité
politique une histoire une culture qui
est plus compliqué que justin groupe qui
représenté par un gouvernement dont vous
comprendrez que c'est une question
extrêmement difficile
comprendre qu'il ya des questions
d'identité de territoire et des
questions au cid qui est sous la loi sur
les antennes de l'époque grossissant à
venir mais très intéressant alors je
vous invite à vous intéresser à ça à
vous intéresser à l'histoire justement
le rôle de gouverneur général et des
relations avec les communautés
autochtones soit une belle semaine